[موسيقى]
عالم فيزيائي رفيع المستوى وكذلك جاسوس من
الطراز الاول شارك بصناعه القنابل القاتله
للامريكيين ثم نقل اسرارهم للسوفييت لكنه
حافظ على سريه نشاطه لمده واحد واربعين
عاما بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه ولم
يعاقب ابدا انه ثيودر هول الجاسوس العالم
فما قصته
ولدت
المعروف بتيودر هول بمدينه نيويورك عام
1925 كان والده تاجر فراء ناجح قبل ان
تتراجع اعماله بسبب الكساد الكبير فعاشت
يودر طفولته في شقاء
في الرياضيات والفيزياء فكان في صغره يقوم
مع شقيقه ادوارد الذي يكبره باحد عشر عاما
بمهام صيانه الكهربائيه بالمنزل وكان
كلاهما ممن يشار اليهما بالذكاء اصبح
ادوارد مهندسا وقام برعايه فيودر حتى نال
شهاده الفيزياء من جامعه هارفارد عام
1942 كان حينها في الثامنه عشره فقط ما
جعله اصغر عالم يتم تجنيده للعمل في مشروع
منهات في مختبر لوس الاموس الوطني في
يونيو عام
1944 بعد ان عمل لعده اشهر منحته جامعه
هارفار درجه اكاديميه عليا ونال ترقيه
لرئاسه الفريق المشارك بتصميم الزناد
الداخلي لاحدى القنابل التجريبيه التي تم
تفجيرها في النهايه بنجاح في موقع تريميتي
في نيو ميكسيكو في السادس عشر من يوليو
عام 19
45 كانت يودر مسؤولا عن تجارب لقنبله
فاتمان من نوع الانفجار الداخلي وساعد في
تحديد الكتله الحرجه من اليورانيوم
اللازمه للقنبله المعروفه باسم
شعرهم بان الاسرار الذريه يجب ان لا تحتكر
ففكر بتمرير بعض الاسرار للخارج وهذا ما
حدث فاثناء اجازه له لمدينه نيويورك في
اكتوبر عام
1944 زار مكتب الحزب الشيوعي هناك لانشاء
جهه اتصال لتمرير المعلومات للاتحاد
السوفيتي
انتهى ذلك بلقاء الكاتب العسكري السوفيتي
الذي اصدر تقريرا عن علماء لوس الاموس
والمعلومات الاساسيه حول القنبله المتفجره
خشي السوفييت في البدايه ان يكون تيودور
عميلا مزدوجا ولكن بعد اختباره تم تعيينه
رسميا كمخبر للاتحاد السوفيتي وحصل على
الاسم الرمزي ام الاي دي وكان ينقل
معلوماته على ورق من الجرائد بحبر سري تم
ذلك خلال لقاءات كان يرتبها السوفييتو مع
العميله لونا كوهي حيث تم اختيار سيده
مهمه لتقليص الشكوك في عام
1946 انتقل هوم لجامعه شيكاغو حيث انهى
درجتي الماجستير والدكتوراه في الفيزياء
لكنه حافظ على الاتصال مع السوفييت قبل ان
يقطعه في اواخر عام
1949 بسبب كرهه لاستخدام الفيزياء النوويه
عسكريا وانخرط بالسياسه متبنيا الفكر
اليساري في عام
1961 قبض البريطانيون على لونا كوهين
لدورها في حلقه تجسس بورت لاند وهو ما ادى
لتولد الشكوك حول هول فتم استجوابه لكنه
نجا لعدم وجود ادله ضده في عام
1962 تمت دعوته للانضمام الى مختبر كافندش
في كامبريدج وهناك تم استجوابه مجددا بسبب
عملته لكن البريطانيين قاموا بتجديد
تصريحه ولم يتم استجوابه مره اخرى طوال
فتره عمله هناك حتى تقاعده في عام
1984 في عام
1996 رفعت الحكومه الامريكيه السريه عن
اجزاء من برنامج بنونا لمكافحه التجسس
الذي اطلقه الامريكان بعد الحرب العالميه
الثانيه وكان من بين هذه الاسرار اكتشاف
عماله هول فتنامت دعوات لمحاكمته مع ذلك
نسيت قضيه هولم مع مرور السنين بل وتمكن
مرارا من الذهاب الى امريكا ونشر له نحو
166 ورقه علميه حتى وفاته في عام
1999 تحدثت يودر في مذكراته عن دوافعه
وافكاره وتجربته في الجاسوسيه كما شارك
تجاربه مع الصحفيين وعبر المنابر
الاعلاميه دون ان يعاقب او ين بذه المجتمع
العلمي